tucked expertly into the bushes out of
view from russian aerial surveillance a
small group of artillerists wait for the
order to unmask their secret weapon
scattered around their very small camp
concealed piles of high precision
munitions
the intensity of fighting work is very
high more than 100 shots are fired out
from the position at the enemy per day
andrey the deputy commander of the
battalion races towards one of his m
triple seven howitzer locations in the
southern harkeev region with global news
the only canadian network granted such
access to protect the security of the
site and the soldiers global is using a
sweeping geographical location
and agreed to limit the visuals of the
m777
there are a few of these sophisticated
weapons in the area provided by canada
the u.s and australia
there are also decoys the battery
commander says they've been able to
destroy russian munition stockpiles
weapons
and provide cover for their frontline
soldiers taking fire or needing to
reposition
long-range weapons are vital for ukraine
as russian troops try to push forward
and snatch more territory in the east
they're working as fast as they can to
reload this m777 right now these ones
can fire up to 28 kilometers away it is
in support of the men on the front lines
around the donbass
after firing several rounds the m7777 is
quickly concealed and the weight begins
to see if the cannon has exposed the
battery's position and fire returns
this time no response from russia the
artillerists have gotten very good at
deploying the weapon position
evo essentially is the first one to
receive them
the battery commander traveled to
germany to be trained on the lightweight
towable weapon returned and trained
others
canada donated an undisclosed number of
m triple sevens to ukraine and nearly
100 million dollars worth of rounds
including fuses and charge banks but the
wish is for high mars the truck mounted
rocket launchers that can move quickly
higher mars is certainly better it is
reactive it fires more shots at the time
as any single howitzer according to
deputy commander andre long range weapon
systems are key
he says artillery is saving the blood of
the infantry
we need them to save troops
crystal gomansing global news
in southern har keep region